[Musik]
hey leute was geht ok das war ich bin
heute einfach etwas übermotiviert etwas
glaubt und jetzt willkommen beim neuen
video ja heute steht was ich seh's grad
schon hier als ich habe mir ein bisschen
was rausgesucht heute steht was wirklich
besonderes an ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich
am titel unten unten unten ja unten
warum unten eigentlich auf jeden fall ab
ist gelesen ich reagiere heute auf
youtube aber nein nicht auf irgendwelche
deutschen youtube sondern ich wollte
ursprünglich auf chinesische youtuber
reagieren nur irgendwie habe ich da
überhaupt keinen durchblick hab ich
wusste gar nicht was das für ein content
ist das hat für mich gar keinen sinn
gemacht ich habe zum beispiel in den
channel gefunden der macht wirklich pro
monat über 90 millionen klicks aber
hatte auf seinem neuesten video
irgendwie so 69 aufrufe dann habe ich
mal so ein bisschen in seinen videos
runter gescrollt und hab dann so gemerkt
er lädt einfach wirklich alle zehn
minuten so ein video hoch was dann
irgendwie 500 klicks macht und kommt
damit dann in 30 tagen auf über 90
millionen gesamt views alter das ist
komplett gestört aber das video war über
das scheiße ich habe zumindest nichts
verstanden und genau deswegen kam mir
die idee reagiert doch einfach auf
japanische youtube und dann ist wirklich
eine menge also ich würde sagen die
japanische youtube szene kann man
ungefähr mit der in deutschland
vergleichen
außer vielleicht dass sie nicht ganz so
asoziales aber so von den abonnenten her
von den usern passt das finde ich weiß
noch schnell sagen wollte ich hätte
natürlich auch genauso gut auf
amerikanische oder türkische youtuber
sonstwas reagieren können also das hat
jetzt nichts mit den japanern zu tun
weil die japaner komisch sind oder so
sondern einfach weil ich irgendwie lust
hatte japanische youtube-videos
rauszusuchen deswegen wenn ihr bock habt
auch noch einen zweiten part und
schreibt doch einfach mal später oder
jetzt in die kommentare auf welche
youtuber aus welchem land ich reagieren
soll
und dann gucken ob ich das machen aber
jetzt will ich wirklich gar nicht an
gelabert ich habe mich eben schon kaputt
gelacht alter das ist echt ich weiß ich
einfach weil man nichts versteht es ist
irgendwie übels witzig also leute
mehrfach an
mit dem ersten youtuber
und er heißt i can t vdk kita kind ev
let's go wege gehen
das intro das müssen wir einfach noch
mal schauen oder das jetzt schon
auswendig
[Musik]
ach so na ich new york so war rücken
baker junis ex abba the show couture wie
die gosse schokosoße schokosoße was ist
das was was hat er eine hand sieht aus
wie so silvesterknaller oder so bin ich
jetzt der sag doch schokosoße oder
vielleicht ist das auch schokosoße ach
so das ist schokosoße kummer
wahrscheinlich steht im titel das ist
ganz klar
baden in 4000 liter schokosoße also der
heg akin macht auf mich auf jeden fall
einen sehr sympathischen eindruck ich
würde mal sagen mal gucken was ist da
noch so gibt der hat wirklich 36
millionen abonnenten
das ist echt eine leistung fast so viele
wie ich so machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten und zwar ist dass der gute alte
wo stellten jetzt hier ein name aber das
ist heimisch wird sagen wir schauen
einfach mal rein kann ja eigentlich
nicht schlimmer werden als in youtube
deutschland
[Musik]
hauptsache der springt da nicht rein
die japaner die sind genauso schlimm wie
wir ja auf jeden fall ein cooler
youtuber ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit einer japanischen dame und
zwar die joker keynote die hat sich
einfach 36 donuts geholt und will die
alle essen ich hatte niemals alter ich
würde jetzt mal so auf 550 kilo maximal
schätzen die hat parteitag schon heute
ist recht kurz 16 teams gegessen ohne
witz ich glaub ich schaffe ich mal sechs
monats das kann doch jetzt nicht sein
oder
wie geht das wie kann so eine zierliche
frau 30 donuts essen sollen die alle
gewinnen du hast du locker film 30
unserem tisch versteckt oder nicht hält
das fand ich jetzt echt gestört also die
japaner wieder nur weil ihr drauf habt
krass jetzt wird mich mal interessieren
wie viele dollars ich schaffe leute wenn
ihr bock habt dass ich mal so viele
donuts esse bis ich wirklich nicht mehr
kann und gucke wie viele ich schaffe das
würden darum nach oben dar warum werde
ich jetzt angerufen auf jeden fall wenn
er darauf beharrt dass man doch nach
oben da irgendwie solchen allen videos
lässt nach oben lass mal zwei damen da
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was da
noch so drauf haben wir machen weiter
mit kind ev gi dp wiz
irgendwie haben die allen ähnliche cent
oder wartet das kann ich auch schon
auswendig senken
die usa state index genommen dass das
video einfach 45 millionen views und nun
16.000 da etwas das bitteschön
verhältnis ich glaub ich hab sogar ein
video was nur 80.000 klicks 28.000 likes
das nicht so gut weg in tv und derzeit
auch wieder vor einer badewanne kann ja
nichts gutes
was macht er da diese diese flasche da
die schwimmer einfach wenn man eine
colaflasche vielleicht gar nichts mehr
aber wenn ich eine melone ins wasser
werfen oder eine coladose die volle
sinkt die nicht auf dem boden das musste
ich gleich mal ausprobieren
[Musik]
ich will so ein vollidiot
ich hab ich gedacht wenn man so dosen
ins wasser wirft die unter am besten
schalte ich das gar nicht mit reinem
sorry habe ich gar keinen plan jetzt
wieder das macht hat die luftballons ist
klar dass hier oben schwimmen
leute ich will sagen ich mache erst mal
stopp ich will ja keinen stress bekommen
wegen corporate oder sonst was auf jeden
fall schreibt ihr mir doch bitte jetzt
meine kommentare wen soll ich noch
anschauen das irgendwelchen anderen
ländern ich habe absolut keine ahnung
wie das video hier war ich an kommt aber
ich werde sie an der bewertung sehen
denke ich mal direkt auf jeden fall ein
snapshot oder instagram abfahrer
irgendwie mal eingeblendet glaube ich
ist es ganz wichtig wir sehen uns dann
am freitag wieder freitag kommt um 14
uhr ein neues video
ich wünsche einen schönen tag morgen
übermorgen bis übermorgen was auch immer
komplexer scheiß nachkommt scheiß drauf
bin